this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
[Music]
reaction what are you doing no breaks
Roxy no time to check your phone we're
going to watch hasmin Hotel the official
Premiere episode we waited four years to
watch this Roxy and now we're finally
here if you did not catch our reaction
to the pilot that is up here on the
channel I did with this person over here
she's Jewish they don't get a hell
anyway we go to go watch this now say
that like it's a punishment so they
don't get a hell they don't get to have
a Hell and Hell looks fun in this show
no we're just in the dirt and the
maggots and bugs eat us until you're
part of the Earth again you know
boring yeah it's crazy that we filmed
the pilot episode four years ago and
then we're wearing the same outfits for
the first episode I have not washed
these clothes in the last four years you
know what to do people leave a like on
this video you're going to want to do
that Satan request it also subscribe
click that notification Bell cuz Roxy
and I are going to be playing catch up
throughout the week hopefully we get to
do these daily uploads that means you
get so much of the maggots over here and
uh thank you to prepper or whomever
maybe me yes calling the Jews maggots is
what I said I said you're the maggot
just you not the Jews don't put words in
my mouth such a Jewish thing to
do okay fine I'm a m thank you full Bank
threat to watch the h seink of with your
own copy of hasman hotel that's
available for super sex reject at our
patreon page over there we cover several
things exclusive with highlights and
watch along included you're ready to see
how they have evolved this now that they
got an insane budget behind it change
some voice actors and then we're going
to compare it and go this is not the
Nostalgia that I remember or this is
better and improved you ready I'm on a
Highway to Hell B Guns and Roses great
band all right stay word to Heaven let's
go
we're g to get an intro oh cool it's it
said an Amazon
series let's go a24 my favorite okay
Bento Box you
l oh fun that's it so short oh she still
gets credit good I wonder if she wrote
it all the episodes once upon a time
there was a glowing City protected by
Golden Gate uh-huh it was ruled by
beings of pure light right angels that
worshiped good and shielded all from
Evil exactly I was saying she was she
has an Angel Heart Lucifer he was a
dreamer with Fantastical ideas for all
of creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of heaven
where they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous what was his way of thinking
so he watched as the Angels began to
expand the universe in their ways from
the dust of Earth they created Adam and
Lilith Lilith equals as the first of
mankind Adam demanded control and Lilith
refused to submit to his
will silly woman Lucifer found her and
the two rebellious dreamers fell deeply
in love together they wished to share
the magic of Free Will with Humanity he
had a good heart offering the fruit of
knowledge to Adam's new bride Eve but
this gift came with a curse for with
this single act of Disobedience evil
finally found its way into Earth with it
a new Realm of Darkness and sin o
as punishment for their Reckless act
Heaven cast Lucifer and his love into
the dark pit he had created never
allowing him to see the good that came
from Humanity wow wow it's like tragic
Lilith thrived empowering demonkind with
her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of Hell grew so did its power
cast in like a feels like light like
beautiful they would send down an army
an extermination to sure hell and its
Sinners could never rise against I no
we're taking heaven I'm on hellside but
Lilith's hope remained and her dream was
pass down to their precious daughter the
princess of Hell there you go we know
her we love her don't worry Mom I'll
make you proud Charlie oh she got a
second hair elastic now did you hear all
that uh yeah that was right there her
voice sounds different I get pretty
worked up after an extermination happens
the story helps she can feel like the
tragic pain of everyone's really feeling
are you okay you know family stuff did
you hear from your mom yet how long has
it been now written by only
seven years seven years but this kingdom
was something she really cared about
something I care about at least you
aren't alone I just hope what I'm trying
to do here will work sounds like
Stephanie beatric all right come on
Alistar says he has something to show us
I hear that it's like I have Lake Bell
in my head because she's so poison ivy
this is so hard in poison ivy but well
hello there you w sin do you like blood
violence and depravity of a sexual
nature yes yeah that's why you're in
hell but what would you say if I told
you there was a place to stay that had
none of that has been Hotel missguided
path to Redemption misguided path by
Lucifer's delusional daughter Charlotte
oh no place your fate in her
inexperienced hand as she tries to work
through her daddy issues by fixing
you
things somewhat functional sta this does
look appealing enjoy riveting
conversation with our singular residence
all L and more at the has been Hotel
desperate attempt at Salvation Starts
Here we still don't have a working phone
what a commercial what the was that
alist I
mean maybe the tone is a bit
off got that smile this makes it look
bad funny I was going for
hilarious the commercial was to let
Sinners know we are trying to help them
well my dear I haven't been active in
hell for some time and everyone
remembers me from my radio show as long
as you get butts in the seats can I
suggest you take better advantage of The
Talented celebrity you have right here
you're a porn star a famous porn star I
would not watch the videos we are not
filming a as a commercial why not sells
don't it a little bit little bit you
film me going at it with Mr fancy talk
creepy voice here you'd be rolling in
participants willing to stay at this
hotel make that fan video and there's
nothing wrong with some sexy time as
long as it's consensual I really don't
want to exploit you in that way you
don't want the hotel exploited this body
was made to be exploited I got the arms
I got the stamina I got the legs I got
the lung
capacity the gag reflex the holes the
chest fluff everyone
think chest fluff wonder if that was a
response to comments probably yeah if
freaky face over there is so powerful
then why can't he just make people stay
here oh trust me I
can you actually think I'd be cleaning
bottles and listening to you [__]
[__] and moan all the time if he wasn't
forcing me I like being forced
keep that
here s Me Whiskers again and I'll Jam
that bottle down your throat come on
keep talking dirty I relate most with
him we can't force Sinners to stay here
they need to choose to that's what I'm
telling you Greg you have to want to get
help yeah it's the way how it usually
works just because nobody has made it
out before doesn't mean it's not
possible see we're trying to get out
whatever means I can keep crashing here
rentree crack is expensive
my dad just called he said that the
leader of the Angel Army wants to meet
he asked if I could go instead but the
extermination just happened what could
they want this soon after I can do
this I'll get Heaven
behind Charlie hold on there's
just a CH it's just a meeting wants to
change their minds and touch their
hearts or what ever angels have oh she's
so endearing this could be swell
something tells me that today will be a
happy day in oh no oh no yes a happy day
in hell don't sing to them that [__] is
halfway down the street oh she's dancing
you actually saw her in the background
that was
cool this sounds so Disney hi mister go
yourself
I'm not doing well oh no poor gu any
Soul change are hard to change I'm so
worried about their friendship
iies yes you can hear the sorrow I open
the door and I give them a place at my
has Hotel there was light before the
darkness show us around the
neighborhood
[Music]
to don't wear holy sh
my Heaven's really the enemy change
their mind and touch my parts uh no he
did the
whole it's going to be a goddamn
nightmare oh there's the lady in the
[__] with like guts or something
awesome awesome awesome awesome that was
like a straight Broadway Banger
yeah oh okay also creepy read the
contract before you sign it especially
in hell baby girl got to keep these
moving though yeah up holy [__] I'm
Charlie my dad asked me if I could meet
you yeah I know okay spoiled nice to
meet you too
oh got you did you see that I recognize
his voice too you weren't here you think
I'd come down there no I mean I love the
vibe totally I love your tunes but it's
such a bummer man everything down there
is just so you know what A pompous
[__] yeah there's a project I've been
working on that I really want to talk to
you about hey hey hey slow down we got
time I love how he's drawn demonic too
we are making a new commercial we need a
camera
Alistair a video
camera all right I love how alistair's
drawn like a classic devil that's what I
said yeah I just I elaborated a tiny bit
more I once it came out of my mouth I
realized and I need a big strong Daddy
to put me in my right it dude well you
come oh yeah to the right place please
cut okay Angel I need you to be less
horny if possible no can you maybe not
have the script in front of your face I
it memorize this [__] sounds like Keith
David so I was playing this gig and for
some reason this virtue chick was
digging on the drummer and it's like do
you know who I am I'm Adam I'm the
original it's like odk that's no no it's
not that's the original Adam I'm the
master who is this wait your name is
Adam Adam like the first man Adam yeah
Adam going to be an angel with Lilith Mr
Adam sir call me dickm Adam you seem
like a smart master I know you are the
leader of the angels and you are a big
thinker a revolutionary a a dickm who
would really love to put his name on
something love putting my name on [__]
shit's the best solution to our biggest
problem Oh herpes yeah that's a [__] no
our other biggest problem oh
uh ugly people that is a real problem
your line is we have the cleanest rooms
okay got it I'm ready
action oh my God into the vo I actually
have to say the line so let's roll again
okay
action oh Nifty is stage fright you're
doing great cut all right see this
episode's entire response to YouTube
comments well they had four years
respond seems like you're having a bit
of trouble there H St why are you even
here I think that's Stephanie beatress I
don't think you're wrong here is Alis
the egocentric piece of [__]
that this face was made for
radio it's like a creepy pasta man
you're going to make this work because
it won't be so entertaining to watch
over an empty Hotel will it [__] ass
[__] ass saying that that's an amazing
cuz you pooped yourself yeah [__] ass I
do this for you and you never ask me to
engage with this frivolous television
technology ever again what is it about
TV you fear so
much fine now
[Music]
then oh how neat all right everyone
let's make a commercial oh my God you
when you take her out for the fifth time
and she still expects you to pay the
check but you're like hey I thought you
wanted
equality our shared problem of
overpopulation in hell oh well that's
not a problem we got that covered what's
happening how many demons did you kill
this year 275 this year sir 275 wao
awesome job not awesome those are my
people he doesn't care that must suck
for
you wow Adam Sinners made mistakes sure
but everyone makes mistakes and then
they're punished forever Angels don't
make mistakes I've never made a mistake
in my life the only reason you're still
here is because daddy gave you and your
hellborne kind a pardon from an exorcist
blade how does that feel to know how
little you matter oh my God oops almost
out of time guess we should get into it
oh no no no angels are just as messed up
I know how's population is out of
control it's a bad situation it's taking
a toll if we rehab these Sinners and
cleanse all their soul SS at my hasband
hotel I know you guys fly down just to
kill once a year and it must be annoying
to S all the way here if they join you
in heaven that trip disappears okay so
it is to get them to Heaven yeah save us
all precious time oh it's like a rock
opera Sor sweetie but there's no def
their F hell is forever you like it or
not but
why
now wow there's noing to
unreal what are my problems with it it
poses like great philosophical questions
did I hear you imply that they don't
deserve death are they winners are they
Sinners cuz it's cut and dry fa is fair
and I for an i no it's not fair at all
who makes the
[Music]
decision extermination is
entertainment oh that what a good line
guaro [__] guitar solo
[__] this is a dope
song a lot of dynamic Duos in this that
I
love what a prick move up the next
extermination what oh my God year to
those little I know it's just been a
week but we'll be back in 6 months 6
months also kind of a commentary on how
we treat the prison system yeah totally
we have something exciting to show you
wait the commercial you all made a new
one yeah one of my better performances
if I do say so myself that's amazing not
going tell them to the HB
Hotel oh no we have just received word
from the heaven Embassy that oh no
extermination is happening sooner than
ever before son of a [__] what does
that mean Katie it means we're all
royally that's definitely a different
voice holy crap that's like way
different see I love like like the Retro
touches they do where it could feel like
semi sci-fi the body six months is the
end of the season of us before they
killed an
angel don't worry when we come back
there won't be a demon left alive to
pull a stunt like this again oh they
didn't kill the angel they Sor in
Stephanie beatric Keith David okay I was
right about those two I don't recognize
any of the other names who did the guy
that I'm talking about we'll look it up
to keep you happy thank you to America's
number one meal kid hellofresh for
partnering with us it's always great to
partner with people whose Services you
actually use because as someone like me
who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time
for healthy eating can be a challenge
that's right for hellofresh has been a
game changer for my life with hellofresh
I get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and delicious recipes
delivered right to my doorsteps so I
don't have to step outside it's
revolutionized my home cooking
experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable keyw I
recently tried their delicious barbecue
pineapple flat RADS and their zucchini
pomodora Panet bake both were
mouthwatering delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian m s fancy and asking my
friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it and the Fuego chicken faito
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time too not having a wait in
line at a grocery store even self
checkouts on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with our
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel Channel and also
support you know having a new lifestyle
healthy affordable lifestyle in the year
2024 go to hellofresh.com rejects free
and use code rejects free for free
breakfast for life you heard that right
one breakfast item per box while the
subscription is active free breakfast
for life for hellofresh.com reject free
use promo code reject free try it out
and let me know your favorite dishes
stay healthy and let's keep enjoying
those movies and shows all right reject
Nation let's get real for a moment
running this channel is incredible but
managing finances especially taxes and
budgeting both for the channel and my
personal life can be overwhelming that's
where rocket money has been a financial
Lifesaver for me even before I ever
partnered up with them like I said I've
been very fortunate to be working with
Brands whose products I already use so
it's a win-win for AWA but it can be a
win-win for you too cuz there's a reason
I use them rocket money is a personal
finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
a heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was
done making it super easy to cancel the
ones you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because Rocky money is a
huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
to up like 20% so if you're ready to
take control of your finances and
there's no better time than now because
it is the beginning of the year check
out rocket money and see how much you
could be saving stop wasting money on
things you do not use so to help support
the channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you oh there's four
episodes out right now I know from the
time of us filming it that's why I said
that's why I said can you be here an
extra hour oh
wow yeah and Roxy was so uncooperative
so difficult to keep her happy that's me
anyway um yo that's a great first
episode yeah or episode two really but
they had a really hard job making it so
that this is a pilot and an episode 2
and I think they did both those things
they didn't rehash any of the old beats
but they did enough explaining so that
if you didn't go watch the Youtube video
of the pilot then you I think you still
would understand what's going on and
what the parameters are and what world
we're in that's true I didn't even oh my
God it's so loud Roxy what's happening I
didn't even think about it like that in
that context and you're so right cuz
like oh what was I'm really glad we
watched the pilot cuz I felt like that
made it exceptionally easier just to
like get on board get into the groove of
it right away it's almost yeah that's
definitely true it was like a pallet
cleanser easing us into this world so
now we know where we are yeah that was a
really cool way to do this um but the
the advanc like you got a clear because
the last episode I mean the pilot it's
kind of weird to talk about it because
the pilot establishes Alistar alisar
Alistar and he's kind of like this wild
card like can you trust him it doesn't
seem like you can actually trust this
guy right no of course not but they
actually gave us a direct villain in the
version of this Adam Angel which to me
seems like Adam killed the angels to to
um you know speed up the uh the next
cleansing right that's what I'm thinking
I don't I don't think they actually
killed an actual Angel you mean Al
you're saying that Adam killed an angel
to use it as an excuse to why they're
going there yeah when you talk about the
pilot there was that villain that we
didn't see in episode one though the
snake guy oh yeah yeah yeah I but it
wasn't like the real villain no just
it's interesting that they clearly it's
like I love that they kept the parts of
the pilot that I wanted them to and then
they retooled it to be like we need a
big bad we need like our entire story
arc and what are we doing here um also
putting in to place like the the seeds
about the mom the dad how long this has
been who is actually riding for our
princess of hell you know I do like that
relationship with her bestie I am
curious if this is a a romantic
relationship or just a bestie s yeah I
think it might just be a bestie but the
show's very queer which I really like a
lot too it's so difficult I can't not
picture Harley Quinn and Poison Ivy so
that's why I feel like it's bordering on
romance oh yeah because I can't get it
out of my head they're so Harley and Ivy
to me in a lot of ways be I feel like
there's probably going to be Alex
Brightman is the guy you keep asking
about can you show me his face yeah dude
I'd be so happy to show you his face
anything to keep you have what is this
oh I do know this guy where do I know
him from I oh Beetle Juice the musical
he this is a guy whose voice is so
distinct that was interesting the voice
actors are great in this um they were
great in the pilot but they're great in
this also do you think they're better do
you want to put the other ones to shame
do you want to put the other ones down
from the pilot I don't I couldn't do you
no no I was just trying to set you up to
get hate comments but didn't take the
bait oh no no I couldn't I think that
they were all great yeah they're all
great this
is I do Wonder one of my Curiosities
about the start of this is um now God
damn it Roxy now I need to know like who
have I've seen this guy before he does
look so familiar uh Blue Bloods he's
done a lot of shows Dracula Teen Titans
Go he's Beetle juu and that so not
Beetle juu and music seen interviewed
before which I watched
okay okay so what I what I am curious
about because some of the they did have
some lines in here that seemed like they
were a response to certain YouTube
comments that came in like the the uh
fluff boobs yeah cuz I because that's
where I would get confused sometimes too
cuz I thought they were boobs I was like
is this like a a trans car what am I
looking at you know no cuz they they
said that it was a um a drag queen oh
okay in the OR at least they they didn't
say that in episode one it was happening
so zigzagging bad when they were
standing outside of the car and getting
thrown the car before the angel dust
drug purchase yeah um and uh they were
like something you don't like a some
like something something in drag or
whatever so I think that they were
saying it was a drag queen must m not
okay no sometimes the lines were going
by so fast and my mind was also keeping
up with like the animation I was so
dazzled by the visuals you know yeah and
also I don't know what they're pulling
from the pilot into episode one what are
you talking about the whole it's one
week later after the pilot no I know but
maybe they you know sometimes they Ditch
things that don't work and so who knows
maybe it is now I well that was one of
my my Curiosities that after we're done
watching I want to look up be because
the this director of it whose name is
the same as the writer Vivian oh and
then the channels like Vivy pops or
something like that okay so Vivian um
okay vivz pop is the YouTube channel
she's had this is coming out four years
later but it takes like a year to put
like an animation show together at
minimum right like especially something
like on this caliber so I am curious a
how long did it take for them to develop
this show the actual Prime video show
and B um
the I'm trying to and B and B you got it
and B um how much did change over the
course of because it seems like they
kind of gave her a cart blunch on
everything she can do especially when
you're partner with a24 who generally
lets you kind of just do whatever the
hell you want so I am curious what did
change from the original plan cuz what
I'm getting at is like usually when
there's a pilot they have like other
episodes in mind or or maybe an outline
maybe scripts right and their show Bible
what changed like and that's kind of
what I was talking about too exactly
about just now what the overarching the
what the season's going to be what the
show's going to be which characters are
the good guys bad guys who has
Redemption well I like it from this
perspective and where you actually see
that cuz you know it it's taking place
in hell and the general rule of thumb is
that the hell bad Heaven good and I like
when they mess with Concepts in in shows
or movies where you actually take the
angels and you pose them as not such
Angelic figures these deities have been
propped up almost the way how like they
deconstruct or or or uh interpret like
Greek gods you know like they think
they're all high and mighty but really
they're like kind of corrupt and messed
up and that's what I like the the
version of the Angel aspect and also
yeah the question the a that that that
con that's one of the concepts of of
religion uh when it comes particularly
to hell that that I've always had a a
struggle with wrapping my head around is
that you know like what warrants someone
being I mean if you're like truly
horrendous like Hitler or like yeah okay
yeah you should be but this idea of like
not living by a certain guideline of the
Bible or whatever to to punish forever
MH I in in the in
torturous hell with no opportunity for
Redemption yeah I think that that's
interesting and and one of the things I
really liked from the pilot to this
first episode is what the first episode
has you question is if you can't get out
of your circumstances is there any point
in changing who you are just to be a
better version of you right and so you
think about that from the hell
perspective Ive but what this first
episode does is shows us that clearly
people who have gone to heaven they were
they really virtuous or were they doing
all of these good things on earth to get
to heaven and then once you get to
heaven if you can't be uh damned to hell
is there any point in continuing to be a
good person exactly and so while they're
in heaven they clearly have changed
their ways and gone to their true nature
because they weren't being good to be
good they were being good to make it to
heaven and so we're watching these
people who are doing who now are more
evil than the people in hell because
they already have been placed and that
means that who they are in their soul
probably deserve to put them in hell
even though they did more good actions
while they were on Earth and there's
also the egotism
of do me a favor can you look up if
egotism is a word yeah hit Apple tea hit
Apple tea you really need me too yeah I
I just need to know hit the Apple button
and what's the Apple button some with
the Apple icon on it see
says Apple command I could have said a
command I could have done that but I I
wasted your time uh egotism egotism is a
word right you know I had something
looked up yes yes okay egotism thank you
egotism everyone everyone egotism is a
word the egotism of that moment the ego
of what what do you mean made me go away
from the thing I had looked up to tell
you
no what are you talking about I looked
something up it was on there I wanted to
tell you about it what did you look up
what I looked up was the girl Vivien who
made the
series she is listed on her IMDb first
as a voice actress so I was like who did
she voice in the series because she's a
voice actress first and it just says
various voices in the show but it
doesn't say anybody specifically it just
says various voices so I'm interested to
see who who she is what she actually
sounds like oh so it it must be kind of
the way how like Seth McFarland voices a
bunch of characters but instead of doing
the main characters they probably do a
bunch of the like secondary random
characters like okay seems like that
anyway go ahead egotism um yeah
so heaven I'm going to stay on track my
ego Will Make
Me That by by getting into heaven it
seems like there is an egotism that does
form a pridefulness that we are better
than because we have made it and
watching that Pride leading to their
fall ultimately I I'm I feel like
there's like a cool world that they have
built here on the in the afterlife that
could lead to like kind of a
catastrophic uh event in some way like I
think there's some cool Universe
building stuff with just a bunch of
musicals and jokes in between when none
of that matters Rox and are here for
serious conversations the music was so
good I mean that was really really well
done it was better I like like the music
and the pilot but I I thought the music
was even stronger in this first episode
I had more money they could produce the
[__] I make it broad that's not a knock
on the pilot that's just I thought that
this was like let's go yeah that I can
imagine she probably got a little bit
more help with uh constructing that
because that straight up seemed I love
when it's like ju supposed with having
um you know music that sounds like a
Disney Disney song but you're getting
just the most um uh lavish nightmarish
deviant violent imagery to place it
against like the wallpaper on while
she's singing so joyous I had a great
time with that I like I I like I really
like the pilot I I like this even more
um I think it's a great I think it's off
to a great start me too I love fish out
of water stories that's kind of what we
have with her but she's also the
connector of these two worlds curious to
see where we go yeah I think it'll end
with a post with with with her Dad or
Mom showing up Lilith and the season
yeah and then uh Lilith has been gone
for seven years so something must have
happened little return she'll be the
ending scene all righty guys what did
you like this first episode more than
the
pilot don't let your Nostalgia Cloud
your judgment that's not to say that
you're wrong if you like the pilot more
I'm just just want you to have an honest
just setting the rules of opinions you
got to just really set it if you don't
agree with me you're wrong that's how it
opinion Works in my mind I agree with
that so I'm right cuz I agree cuz you
agree with
me I'm run a tight ship around here
people let's watch episode dose rockan
here we go one more time call you Rocky
sometimes who mostly horror and picture
show those are people's names
yep I think I like this bit those are my
friends
my friends hor picture show yeah and
bboa someone asked this question
before is this is this a joke you've
done before no why do should I tweak
it yeah I think we should Workshop it a
little
bit that was an unexpected answer all
right all right we're out
atie